depuis le 29 septembre dernier evelyne
bernard propriétaire d'un club de
fitness a entamé une grève de la faim
une banderole a également été déployée
sur la façade de son club
désormais vidée de ses adhérents
objectif faire réagir le gouvernement à
propos des nouvelles mesures de
restrictions mises en place dans
l'hexagone
selon la dirigeante la décision de
fermer les salles de sport et
inappropriée et injuste quand une
entreprise afin sa salle lui envoyer des
miettes de pain parce que ça ne touche
qu elle a perdu en amont donc tout ce
qu'on a perdu au niveau d'août chiffre
d'affaires etc
on le récupérera pas je pense que nous
avons tout fait depuis le dernier
confinement nous avons tout mis en place
et il n'y avait aucune raison que nous
sommes enfermés injustement parce que
aujourd'hui personne n'est venu dans nos
clubs du gouvernant je parle d'un
gouvernement ministère de la santé peu
importe personne n'est venu dans nos
clubs pour réellement nous dire ouais
vous êtes hyper dangereux vous êtes non
personne et ça c'est ce que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi ne pas faire du
cas par cas
il n'y a pas eu de contrôle n'y a rien
eu face à la détresse de cette gérante
bon nombre d'habitués ont décidé de lui
apporter leur soutien devant la salle
une séance de sport improvisé s'organise
dans la bonne humeur coacher
participants sont unanimes
aucun risque de contamination au sein du
club grâce aux mesures de précaution on
est tous là pour soutenir et vieux
pendant sa grève de la faim c'est un
moyen pour nous de dire qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec cette fermeture est du
coup bah voilà on essaye de toujours
garder la forme et la santé
parce que c'est important ce moment
depuis la fin du confinement
été mis en place aussi pour que les
gestes barrière soir contre ascq en
permanence nous
on a des flexibles pour nous protéger
les uns des autres on a un sens de
circulation avec des chats on peut pas
c'est impossible d'attraper le
communisme la métropole de lyon fait
désormais partie des sommes placées en
alerte maximale
depuis le 26 septembre dernier les
salles de sport de la région sont tenus
de fermer leurs portes
pour l'heure cette fermeture doit durer
15 jours